[Musique]
on dirait que frais ambiance humide
samedi dans la nuit pour cette septième
édition de la caldeira trail près de 700
coureurs au départ pour ces deux formats
65 et 47 km et selon la stratégie
l'ambition n'est pas la même pour
je connais que le parti a la sensation
et voir s'ils avaient su se réveille aux
intérêts
ces petits vaisseaux sans selle qui
l'obligent à saluer km qui est en son
nom et annonçant qu'elle attend vos
cibles turques à dos rond qui le plus
haut taux possible voilà
eh ben les bourgs bien plus qu'un
[Musique]
si courir pouvait être le projet la nuit
a donné le thème de la journée a quand
même le passage de trois caldera qui se
sont formés avec le temps ne laisse
personne indifférent
[Musique]
bédié l'a l'apéro ici c'est pas mal
après une montée super raid des galets
de la boue des torrents et on remonte le
long de cette caldera forcément on est
récompensé par un paysage magnifique
visite d'ailleurs ah ouais c'est beau
mais toutes ces informations sur la
découverte du territoire
vous pourrez les voir dans le prochain
épisode de terre de trail c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on sait qu'une fois
[Musique]
le passage de tous les étages de
végétation dans cette forêt
départementaux de magna l' offre ici
l'un des plus beaux spots de notre île
[Musique]
avec 12,7 millions d'euros consacrés
chaque année à l'entretien et à
l'aménagement des vingt trois espaces
naturels sensibles
ajoutez à cela 900 km de sentiers et 365
aire de pique nique notre nature offre
une multitude de couleurs justes pour
notre bonheur quand vous regardez la
télé depuis votre canapé
et ouais je sais web alors les gars là
ce bureau sans rien de ça va donner
quel intérêt d'être tout seul en forêt a
profité des bruits ouais les eaux de
l'eure a c'est vrai une atmosphère quand
même y'a pas à dire et puis surtout
micropole ah ça c'est bon ça la descente
vers saint philippe permet le passage
dans la forêt vierge de mare longue
avant une ligne d'arrivée bien mérité
[Musique]